die ehemalige komplizin und ex geliebte
von jeffrey epstein jazz lane maxwell
plädierte am dienstag vor gericht auf
nicht schuldig sie streitet eine
beihilfe in den missbrauchsfällen ab und
für uns verfolgt den prozess in den usa
herbert bauernebel er hat uns bereits in
der nacht eine erste einschätzung
übermittelt die mutmaßliche komplizin
des sex verbrecher jeffrey epstein
gilliam maxwell hatte gehofft dass sie
gegen kaution auf freien fuß gesetzt
werden könnte doch die richterin in dem
bundesgerichts gebäude in lower
manhattan hinter mir kannte keine gnade
die kaution wurde abgelehnt maxwell war
zugeschaltet bei diesem ersten hearing
nach ihrer verhaftung anfang des monats
aus einem hochsicherheitsgefängnis in
brooklyn mit einem video link sie hatte
ihre haare zurückgebunden wirkte meist
gefasst dann allerdings als die
richterin entschied dass es keine
vorzeitige entlassung gegen kaution gibt
kamen ihr dann doch die tränen mehrmals
wischte sie sich mit dem index finger
tränen von den augen ihre verteidigung
hatte alles versucht um sie frei zu
bekommen zumindest während des
vorverfahrens es wurde angeboten eine
kaution in der höhe von fünf millionen
dollar doch die richterin führte dann
doch die argumente der
staatsanwaltschaft an dass die
fluchtgefahr einfach zu groß wäre beides
gelehnt max will nach dem ja auch
bekannt war dass sie selbst als das fbi
an der haustüre stand in ihrem versteck
in new hampshire sie noch versucht hat
zu flüchten es wird eine lange u-haft
werden für gm maxwell denn die richterin
sagte der prozessbeginn wird erst im
juli des nächsten jahres am 12 juli 2021
beginnen